in our chief political correspondent
john craig who
joins me now john what did you make of
those
opening stages of the debate 12
powers that uh mr hancock announced to
being taken out
so just to recap what's happening they
are voting to extend
the coronavirus act that's the emergency
legislation
for another six months takes us up to
the 25th of september
at the same time they're voting to ex
extend or maybe a second vote on that
extend the regulations the current
regulations or most of them
uh for another three months that takes
us to the end of june beginning
of july and you'll also have heard mr
hancock talk about
um some extending proxy voting and
virtual participation
in parliament until the 21st of
june that's the day of step four in the
prime minister's road map
now we just heard jonathan ashworth
there
uh give a warning that the pandemic's
not over
the virus is surging again uh but
uh mr hancock who as you rightly say
sarah
took a lot of interventions from tory
back ventures including quite a few from
mark harper who chairs the uh coved
recovery group of conservative mps
this was the very the rather pithy and
succinct way that he summed up
why the government wants to extend these
powers
the coronavirus act is temporary it's
time limited
it's proportionate to the threat we face
and we're only keeping measures where
they are necessary
as we exit this pandemic and then we can
do away with this act
for good
do away with this act for good he
promised well certainly uh conservative
mps
will be pleased to hear that of course
earlier today the prime
minister has been talking about
something he rather
sprang on us all at the liaison
committee
of senior mps last night uh passports
for pubs or whatever you call it papers
for pubs
pm's been talking a bit more about that
today that surprisingly rather
surprisingly
mr hancock hasn't been quizzed on that
during this debate
uh he's been concentrating more on the
legislation
the uh the papers for pubs the idea that
you might need to have a
vaccination certificate either
electronic or on paper
or evidence of a negative test that's
something that's likely to be part of a
review
uh on the whole idea of vaccine
certification that's been carried out by
michael gove the cabinet office minister
it may well be that when he reports
he will recommend that that may be
brought in
in return for relaxing rules on social
distancing
in pubs restaurants entertainment venues
and so on
but for now what's going to happen in
the commons later this afternoon
is as you just heard dame elena lang in
the chair say
she's one of the deputy speakers um
they're on to backbencher's speaker
speeches four-minute limit uh voting
starts at five o'clock
uh there will be um votes because there
are conservative rebels
uh one suggestion from steve baker one
of the rebels yesterday
was there could be as many as 60 well i
think that's a bit high
but they will no doubt force a division
uh steve baker had tabled an amendment
it was not selected by
sir lindsay hoyle the speaker so
there'll be a vote
on extending the coronavirus act on
extending the uh uh the regulations
controversial ones including that travel
ban with a
5 000 pound fine um and
uh i would have thought the the uh
change the extending the
virtual participation and the uh uh
proxy voting in the commons they're
almost certainly going to go through on
the nod so
probably a couple of votes at five
o'clock big majority obviously because
labour as jonathan ashworth has just
indicated
are going to back uh these uh proposals
um but he had some comments about
underfunding of the nhs which meant the
nhs wasn't
properly prepared for the pandemic he
repeated labour's calls
for a public inquiry um mr hancock on
the other hand is just concentrating
on the provisions in front of mps so
we're on to back bench speeches now
we'll hear from some of the rebels like
charles walker
and steve baker and mark harper during
the course of this debate between now
and five o'clock
when the voting starts john